♫ La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la
♫ la, la, la, la, la, la, la ♫
("Raw Revival")
- We have space camp.
- Ranked most prepared
for a zombie apocalypse.
(groaning noises) Oh!
- You like canyons?
We've got a grand one.
- (whistles) Oh, we have
the most dog owners.
- Most professional sports teams.
(whistle) Nothing but net.
- We've got disproportionately
more gluten free stuff
as compared to the national average.
- An old timely nickname
for us is the Nutmeggers.
- Home to the Punkin
Chunkin World Championship,
this thing where they
use a bunch of devices
to throw pumpkins.
- Second largest ocean
coast line after Alaska.
- We're number one in barbecue.
- State where you're least
likely to collide with a deer.
- We produce 72 types of precious
and semi precious stones.
- Deep dish pizza.
- The Indianapolis Motor Speed Way
is the world's largest
spectator sporting facility.
- We've got the highest
population of pigs.
Look at those pigs.
- Home to one of the two
largest balls of twine.
Where's the other one?
- We have the longest cave system.
Whoa.
- We've got the most single people.
- We've got the oldest population.
- The state sport is jousting.
- Home to the top three most Irish towns.
- Colon, Michigan is the self-proclaimed
magic capital of the world.
- We've got the most golfers per capita.
- (yawns) We get the most
sleep per night on average,
tied with Alabama.
- Wow, birth place of Mark Twain,
and where most of his
famous stories took place.
- Residents view it at as
the best place to live,
tied with Alaska.
- We got the most homes
with indoor plumbing.
- Do you like what you see?
Prostitution is legal in parts of Nevada.
- The first free public library
was founded here in 1833.
- First state to ratify
the Bill of Rights.
- We have the highest
population of Hispanic people.
- Birth place to the most astronauts.
- First public university.
Oh thank you, I did it.
- We got the largest penises.
- We're the most likely
to mother (bleep) curse.
♫ Oklahoma has a musical
written about it ♫
- But I've never seen it.
It looks great though.
- Portland, Oregon has the
most strip clubs per capita.
- We're home to Gettysburg,
Independence Hall,
Liberty Bell, and Valley
Forge National Park.
- More Rhode Islanders over the age of 12
smoke marijuana monthly
than any other state.
- We're the most polite
state, thank you very much.
- Cows outnumber people over four to one.
- Home of Jack Daniels, the
best selling American whiskey
in the world.
- Texas has the most deaths
from hands, fists, and feet.
- We're number one in volunteerism.
I'm not even getting paid for this.
- We've got the most craft
breweries per capita.
- We got the most vanity
license plates per capita.
- We're the least likely
to gosh darn curse.
- Home of the first
Mother's day celebration.
Happy Mother's Day.
- (inhales) Cheese.
- 92.7% of the population is Caucasian.
("Raw Revival")